and now it's time for bomb reviews with
Chester a are tonight's review inter
star oh my god this is a greatest movie
I've ever seen in my life
do not go gently into that spoilers
there's this guy who's a way too many
linking commercials even though
everybody's made fun of them and yet
they still keep playing them seriously
why are you still playing them and he's
upset because the world is being
consumed by a giant sand fart I was
consumed by a giant sand fart once it
was coarse rough and irritating and it
gets everywhere but he has a daughter
who thinks the house is haunted by
Paranormal Activity ghosts and she's
like the books in sand are falling in
the form of Morse code you've been
drinking I mean what kind of hate ends
up believing her because he always plays
his role like a constantly tipsy man I
am in the gullible part of being tipsy
so I will believe you
they're coordinates I thought their
coordinates even before you pay me to
think they were coordinates so they
drive to the coordinates in the middle
of his top-secret place which is so top
secret in the claim nobody can find it
that all they put up for security is a
fence I mean there's an alarm and guards
and stuff but really it's still just a
fence a fence but it turns out this is
where NASA is hiding and will soon
regret letting this movie use their name
see how much double-crossing and lying
there isn't it and it turns out they're
looking for a new world that's not being
consumed by a same fart and Alfred is
like you're the only one who can fly all
spaceship will you fly it for us well I
just doubled across you I mean what are
the chances I stumble across you you
need a pilot for your ship and I'm the
only one you know Christopher Nolan
movie very strong so are you in I like
to but I'm in the distracted part of
being tipsy I'm just gonna say all my
lines looking off screen because
something off that catches my attention
yeah I can't believe you won an Oscar I
think that's a Lincoln so he agrees to
leave the world because some entity out
there is sending us a wormhole to travel
the new world and Catwoman is like as
pilot of the ship I expect you to ask
questions about this mission that you
sure that's months in advance but
instead I'm just gonna act like before
we do the thing I'd like to do okay but
I'm suddenly in the intrigued part of my
tips in this so I have to ask will it be
a sassy robot that is
stupidest thing I've ever what yes there
will be a sassy low back can we call him
Lincoln No so the robot is named tars
and he looks like a giant walking
monolith from 2001 which is one of many
sci-fi films this movie will constantly
rip off and tars it's like I am an
incredibly emotional and funny robot but
we're already emotional beings why do
they give you a motion because
Christopher Nolan characters are so
lifeless they actually figured out robot
would have more personality we'll just
tell me you're not gonna get overly
emotional make stupid decisions because
of it no that's Anne Hathaway's job
that's right now let me constantly be
saved endanger the mission to talk about
how love is the key to everything look
for a Lincoln oh don't don't do that
we're home they discover these three new
worlds before them and Oh heavenly
majesty Oh creative of all creativity
what do these three worlds look like
one's a notion one's all eyes and one's
a desert by God the imagination of
science fiction knows no bounds but
there is a downside to a movie full of
nothing but downside they made a mistake
and they've been gone only a few hours
but that means 23 years on earth and
even in all that time McConaughey's
daughter has never forgiven him this is
a video message from my dear tell you
that I still never forgiven you but
because you selfishly ran off to save
the world
what sure but it turns out the daughter
grows up to be a super genius and she
finds out something terrifying from
Alfred or at least it would be
terrifying if we could understand what
he was saying yeah uh-oh what uh-oh what
you know what I'll just wait for you to
explain so the audience can understand
this is a video message saying that the
earth is doomed
thank you so the answer nice try to
figure out which plan to go to next and
Catwoman is like I think it should be
the icy one because I fell in love with
the astronaut that none of you have seen
okay we have got to tone down this
emotional stick why because I'm a woman
that you think I feel to know cuz I'm in
the philosophical stage of my tipsy
acting and now I'm starting to get all
sorts of fields why don't we say
emotional keywords that are great for
the trailer all right uh-huh
look forgiveness hope determination
future Lincoln so then go to the plan
and they find the room kind of sort of
not really boyfriend is not there but
instead he's another robot to play my
back David we are Earth's only hope
because philosophically we are the ones
they have to survive
that's a rule that I think that's just
no Liz lady but it's absolutely and
important you're in the poetic part of
your tipsy face aren't you I think so
I'm stunned by that love connects us all
bullcrap you said so as we get closer to
the end they decide to wrap up this
incredibly greedy this incredibly adult
this incredibly realistic sci-fi drama
with the fistfight in spacesuits
you know this really doesn't seem
appropriate without the sixty Star Trek
music you're right but then they realize
there's only one possible thing that can
save them science mumbo-jumbo if you
break the calculations that the gap
Anita's father Walter Dimmick conahey
goes into the wormhole and it turns out
he can communicate with his daughter
inside her room so the daughter figures
out a way for Humanity to survive and
McConaughey gets out of the loophole
just before she dies and she's like
don't worry about me I'm just dying go
save that Catwoman chick okay so he
steals one of NASA spaceships which they
probably would have just given to him
anyway if I tell the hell did he steal
this security really still just a fence
and he goes to save Catwoman because I
guess that's what this movie was all
about either they're he's just going to
pick up a Lincoln Lincoln the end so
interstellar really challenged the idea
of such base and time in that it makes
you sit in one space for a very very
long time for a while I thought the
movie theater was everybody's new home
which I really would have liked come on
can i renovate some of the popcorn boxes
Barry start laying out where the
bathroom should be and by laying out at
me taking a she sees just really boom
saying
oh come on never Gaea we have come on J
come on maybe we can get inception an
interstellar to combine in sense Devin
you